ladies and gentlemen good morning it's a
great pleasure for me to be here it's a
great honor to represent burak the board
of European regulators for electronic
communications and I'm very happy to be
in my for the first time in the ftth
council conference in this in such a
vibrant city like war so and as we saw
and we heard with so many plans to
develop to deploy fiber network and as
chair of barrick I'd like to start by
reflecting and ask you to reflect with
me about the challenges we have for the
next five years I want to think about
the future and I want to tell you how at
barrick we are working towards a future
proof regulation if we think about the
future of the electronic communication
sector the first thing we should do is
to wear what I could call some broadband
glasses I mean we need to look at the
sector from several perspectives because
we are living in a high-speed changing
world and as regulators we have the
obligation to look ahead to make a
forecast about our role in the future we
need to find the most efficient
proportionate and least intrusive
regulatory approaches as you know
regulators are blamed by the sector by
stakeholders that say that we are very
conservative that we don't look
sufficiently ahead so I want to tell you
that we want to change our reputation we
want to be forward-looking because as
Magdalena said the future is now and if
we look at our market
well some years ago our task was much
simpler we had a single market with well
defined borders and we know what to do
we had to prevent forming monopolies to
you know dominate the market we should
ensure access and the services were
quite simple voice text messages some
data but today the world changed and the
borders of our the comfortable borders
of our sector vanished they are almost
gone and we must we feel a bit lost in
this quite changing world because the
convergence of sectors like IT
telecommunications in media has created
a new digital ecosystem where
traditional business models are no
longer valid business models that are
continuously changing and entering
different sectors and of course this is
bringing new challenges to operators
that missed that as well to this new
ecosystem but also for regulators
because we are pretty sure that new
bottlenecks may arise within barrick I
don't know if you are aware of this but
we are 28 members so we are the national
regulators from 28 EU state members and
9 observers working together on the
development and sharing of regulatory
best practices aiming to implement the
European Union framework regulatory
framework and also to promote an
effective single market one of our main
tasks is to advise in the cysts European
Commission in the depth in the
development of internal market as we
have been doing recently in our in areas
like roaming net neutrality currently
under discussion in the context of the
connected continent regulation
because we also serve as a body for
reflection debate and device for the
European Parliament the Commission and
European Council in the field of
electronic communications barrack feels
that must take the lead and pave the way
for the discussion on the required
regulation for the next five years so
let's look at some key issues while
looking forward when we talk about
technology market trends and the future
challenges for regulators the so-called
OT tease come to our minds by the way
let me tell you that at varick we
decided that oddities don't exist
anymore we will call them caps content
and applications providers because this
is what they really are and caps are
part of the ecosystem and they are part
of the challenge for operators in the
sector and also for regulators but we
need to sync brother we need to consider
the explosion of machine-to-machine the
Internet of Things and the internet of
everything we need to foresee the impact
of bundle services which in a couple of
years will probably bandel a wide
variety of services we had three play
for a fifth play who knows how many we
will have in the future and this of
course will bring new challenges for
regulation and what about network
convergence and quality of service and
all IP networks all of these will
contribute to shape the new digital
ecosystem and how will we deal with
issues like privacy and data protection
network in information security because
we cannot close our eyes we know that
security is already the key word
remember that cloud services are the
future that most of us use
location-based services that the annual
IP traffic in 2016 will pass the
zettabyte and that number of services
connected to IP networks will be nearly
twice as high as the global population
in 2018 according to Cisco so these
numbers look quite impressive but can we
go further this brings us to the demand
side of the equation we were talking we
heard Magdalena talking about demand we
know that people are hunger for an fast
speed broadband however in spite of
these we must be aware that somehow in
the demand we can define a kind of two
tiers we have the people that are hungry
for fast speed but on the other side we
have many people that the network
deployment is you know some somehow
contingent on the fact that part of the
demand is limited because there is low
affordability accessibility and digital
literacy and we cannot forget this
network deployment is worthless if don't
have a significant pick up and as you
know I come from a country and I'm very
proud of it a country where you know we
have like eighty-five percent of nga
coverage and we have and in terms of
fiber to the home the coverage rate is
fifty percent but if you look
at the take-up the take-up is much lower
than the european average so we are
together with Sweden we are on top of
the European countries in terms of FTTH
networks however to take out the take-up
is low given to many many elements and
some of them are connected to economic
conditions but also to digital literacy
you have people like the young people
that we just saw that cannot live
without a high-speed broadband but we
have some people that are quite happy
with adsl and so they don't want to pay
right now a premium price for another
type of connections however this is
changing and this is changing very fast
and the demand will take some time to
develop but you cannot the demand cannot
wait for the infrastructure to be built
so right now we have the infrastructure
and we will wait for the demand and we
need today to be sure that coverage and
take up not need to be part of an
equation that we definitely need to
balance without this balance we do not
solve the problem of incentives to
invest demand for high speed broadband
is ultimately the main driver for
investment but the regulatory landscape
is also changing in the European Union
there is a new commission and the new
Parliament some policies like Europe
2020 and the Digital Agenda will soon be
reviewed and the right radio spectrum
policy program and European Union data
protection framework will also be
revised and all these will absolutely
have an impact in the sector but the
most significant of
these regulatory developments is
definitely the review of the European
regulatory framework this is what we
read in perak consider a priority for
2015 and therefore we want to be
prepared to support the Commission on
this crucial task we expect an ambitious
reflection and the disruptive one within
barrack we are looking closely at a near
future we are studying the trends and we
are analyzing the different scenarios we
are discussing with global stakeholders
to fit and they reach our forecast we
considered that going for a minor
changes for the framework review will
not work because the world will be
radically different from what it was in
2002 when the directive was written 2009
when it was revised today in 2015 the
world will be much different in two
years in three years can you imagine
five years and we now must think about
the regulation for the next five years
so we must try to understand how the
world will change and what will be the
role of regulators in this new ecosystem
the new regulatory framework will have
to be ready to regulate coagulate
deregulate in the new digital ecosystem
and for this to happen we need to push
for a deeper change as you can imagine
this is a big challenge for regulators
that in general prefer to be rather
conservative because it's safer we know
our space our little world and now we
must challenge ourselves to be
forward-looking and try to you know to
see what is the regulation that we will
need in the future and now
just to try to adapt the current
regulation for the future in short
barracks strategy for the next three
years aims at thing taking full account
of this technological and market trends
as well as the coming regulatory
landscape we are in a turning point and
it's absolutely necessary for Barrick to
Ford see the evolution of the echoes of
the ecosystem in the coming years one of
the barracks strategic pillars is to
promote effective competition and we
cannot forget this why because in doing
so we are promoting efficient investment
and innovation in new and enhanced
infrastructures and services our
understanding is that effective and
sustainable competition is what drives
efficient investment and not the other
way around ladies and gentlemen if we
want to boost European digital economy
if we want he health he'd patient and
cloud computing services if we dream
with smart cities and interactivity if
we won't reach audio-visual services and
so on we cannot continue to think
broadband what we do need is to focus on
the deployment and take up a fast and
ultra-fast broadband has a conference
model suggests let's all push for a
water fast connected Europe thank you so
much
you